welcome
to the void black holes remain
the most mysterious and destructive
force
in our universe and when one explodes
the devastation permanently changes the
structure of the universe
but what if not one but
all the black holes in the universe
suddenly exploded
would you die instantly
or would gravity suck you in
and how could you use this cosmic event
to book yourself a journey in time
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if every black hole suddenly exploded
in 2016 astronomers discovered the
remnants of an explosion from a
supermassive black hole almost 400 light
years from earth
the event ripped through space and
created
a cosmic crater wide enough for 18
milky way galaxies to fit inside
this one blast ripped apart the office
galaxy cluster
and raged for over 100 million years
but what did it take to ignite its fuse
a black hole which is the remains of a
dead star
contains a large concentration of matter
squeezed into a tiny area and
its gravitational field becomes so
strong that all matter and even light
gets sucked into its vortex the milky
way galaxy alone
contains over 400 million black holes
yeah in the center of our home galaxy
there's a super massive black hole over
million solar masses wide and
studies have found that most galaxies
have
these gravitational monsters at their
core
these super massive black holes like the
one in our backyard
can expand to billions of times the size
of the sun
so is our galaxy a ticking
time bomb what an engaging question
and since i use grammarly premium every
line i write whether it's an email
a project or a script comes across as
more precise and thought-provoking
grammarly premium allows you to set
goals for your writing and it offers
vocabulary suggestions to avoid
overusing words
make your writing focused clear and
dynamic so it's
ready for any audience with grammarly
premium
you can streamline your workflow to cut
down on editing time and
write more confidently and you can get
twenty percent off grammarly premium
by signing up at grammarly.com slash
what if
that's twenty percent off at g r a m
a r l y dot com slash what if
sign up today because unlike that
explosion
this deal won't last forever
now speaking of black holes one percent
of these giants
has a swirling mass of gas and dust
called an accretion disk the orbiting
debris from this disk
falls inside the black hole and shoots
out at nearly the speed of light
guided by twisted magnetic fields the
metals and radiation would
burn brightly and return to the cosmos
debris from the accretion disk endlessly
feeds this
giant singularity but what would it
take for this behemoth to explode
the black hole would have to take in
over 300 million solar masses of gas
to create an explosion greater than the
one that tore apart the ophiuchus
cluster
and the amount of gas it displaced would
equal
several trillion suns across the
universe the blast would
rip galaxies apart and destroy planets
and depending on the amount of gas it
took in
the explosion could continue for
hundreds of millions of years
unfortunately for planet earth we
lay right in the path of a jet stream
from sagittarius a
the supermassive black hole in the milky
way
super hot particles ejected from the
black hole
would slam into our planet along with
lethal levels of radiation
once the x-ray and gamma-ray photons
reached earth
they would destroy the ozone layer
within months
with this protective layer gone how long
would it take for
the radiation to fry the planet
it would take over 1 000 years for those
gamma rays to hit our planet if
the closest black hole h.r 6819
exploded so while we might see
several hundred new bright spots in the
sky it
would take a millennium before our
planet would feel its effects
i mean if we're still around
this cataclysmic event wouldn't destroy
the entire universe
just large parts of it but
the same materials left behind from the
blast
would create the seeds for new life
over hundreds of billions of years these
particles could become
new stars galaxies or even
life on earth time near the
edge of the black hole would appear to
last billions of years
and near the border of the singularity
an object would seem to hover there
endlessly
but what would happen if earth
were sucked into a black hole
well as always that's a story
for another what if
you